it's estimated that nearly 700,000
people buy something at more than
160,000 garage sales held in the US
every week but we're gonna show you one
that soars above all the others Delta
Airlines has a monthly surplus sale that
has aviation fans lining up for a
sky-high shopping flight of fancy Kris
Van Cleave was there once a month the
line starts early
a little after 7:00 on a hot humid
Friday morning in Atlanta hello welcome
to the sale
two hours later Judy bean opens the door
to a nondescript small building in the
shadow of the world's busiest airport
enjoy yourself we have the t-shirts for
a dollar apiece welcoming people by the
hundreds to a one-of-a-kind garage sale
where things that were once flying high
from Delta Airlines find new homes on
the ground it's always like treasure
hunting that hunt was cleared for
takeoff the first folks through the door
raced to land the eight retired galley
carts shelling out up to a hundred and
fifty dollars apiece to wheel them out
the door the bigger challenge for
Larissa Marsh is how to get her
soon-to-be bar cart home to Florida six
hours away you're gonna drive all the
way back to Tampa like this yes we're
gonna get some fresh eggs and get it
back
Apryl Gilbert is one of the first
through the door every month this time
she found a life-sized picture of a
cabin door it'll go nicely in her office
which she admits has become a bit of a
shrine to the Delta surplus sale I found
that the earlier you come the better
success you have among the best stuff
this month rows of first-class seats
from a newly retired md-88 yours for
$300 a piece a basket of brand-new
surplus delta silverware dishes in some
cases decades old and pieces of aviation
history
Judy bean has run the surplus sales
since 2005 they started 10 years earlier
as an effort to get rid of extra office
furniture no other US airline does this
all sales are final and there's no
haggling on the price is it unusual to
have the first-class seats
well yes generally we just have coach
seats before this gig she worked for the
airline for 35 years and just hates to
see something Delta go to waste or worse
get thrown away people walk in and
they're thrilled at the stuff that's
here you know my philosophy is I'll try
to sell it once or twice and then if it
doesn't go it can be a bit overwhelming
to witness but the proceeds from the
sale about a hundred thousand dollars a
year go to benefit the Delta flight
museum I'm gonna kill me but I'll put my
name on it of the thirteen thousand one
hundred six dollars that rolled in
during this five-hour sale nearly 500
were from Joshua golden who came in from
Idaho I'm grinning from cheek to cheek
I'm just excited about everything that I
got I was worried that I wouldn't get
any of it today
stopping in North Carolina to pick up a
truck this Delta superfan was looking to
trick out his new apartment in Maine
he's leaving with a beverage cart Delta
directors chairs in his own form of
first class it saw this thing and saw
that the trade tables still are
functional and I said
I just can't say no to it over the years
they've had people to part with some
unique stuff overhead bins jump seats
someone paid $500 for a pressurized
cabin door from a dc9 those are airplane
galleys a tail cone from an MD 88 even
the beds flight attendants used to rest
during long-haul flights David Bell who
works in Delta's maintenance department
comes every month looking for something
that's a little different he found it
what made you go I want the airplane
bathroom in my house just to see if it
could be done
Bell bought the 757 lab at the surplus
sale and installed it in his basement
mancave what is the reaction when people
come to your house and see the airplane
bathroom does it work and can't believe
you put this in here it sits next to the
cabin interior complete with overhead
bin and window cutouts he's made into a
bit of a home office and that's a coach
seat he turned into an office chair your
family's not like come on man you got
them you got the bathroom is nothing new
my wife we've been married for 37 years
she knows knows that truly one airlines
trash is another man's bathroom sized
conversation piece of treasure for CBS
this morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Atlanta you know before before that
story and I said why would anyone want
to buy these things from an airplane now
I want now you know now oh now you know
do you want now that's one of the major
mancave definitely go to the man cave I
respect that I'm still in shock I spent
too much time on planes but I can't
expect it yeah all right well from